une semaine à vélo et 650 km c'est le
défi brillamment relevé des très jeunes
dès que vit à raison de six à sept
heures de vélo par jour c'est avec
satisfaction qu'il revienne d'une course
avec son petit quota de difficultés ça
s'est bien passé ces escrocs c'était
plus difficile que les précédentes
années avec la pluie
dans les cars 2 on est content et on
voit que ça leur a fait plaisir aussi en
plus c'est une bonne initiative d'y
aller ça leur permet aussi bad
d'encourager et de dd à l'orme à leur
manière cette cause une course qui a
demandé une grande logistique avec plus
de 40 personnes les dons sont reversés à
la ligue contre le cancer une façon
d'honorer la mémoire de l'un de leurs
camarades victimes de la maladie c'est
la sensibiliser c'est pour cela qu'en
fait on s'est mobilisé pour ce projet là
surtout hao décès du coup de
une personne de notre âge qui est mort
ici est que vit on a tous un parent un
membre de la famille ou un ami qui est
touché donc parfaite par ces maladies
malheureusement et il était important du
coup bâti intéressés et puis surtout bat
des cils en quelque sorte d'accompagner
ces personnes au delà de ce projet les
jeunes ont surtout pu apprendre
l'entraidé la solidarité on voit que nos
jeunes aient quevillois sont des
personnes extraordinaires solidaire et
ce qui m'interpelle énormément c'est
leur jeune âge leur jeune âge et partir
comme ça durant leurs vacances prendre
du temps
je trouve ça vraiment exceptionnel mais
rester solidaire ça on a récolté 5 5200
euros versé un bon truc pour l'année
contre concerne ça fait plaisir en fin
de journée a lieu la remise des
médailles de la ville une fierté pour
ces jeunes qui envisagent déjà une
potentielle édition l'année prochaine